ukrane claims that this is the moment a
Russian ship was ordered to ram a
Ukrainian naval boat on the Black Sea
the incident happened on Sunday
afternoon shots were also reportedly
fired and Russian Special Forces boarded
the three boats he seized them six
ukrainian sailors are said to have been
injured and the ukrainian President
called an emergency session of his war
cabinet they met late into the night
according to preliminary information six
naval officers were wounded some were
wounded some were traumatized during the
operation on board the vessels two naval
officers were severely injured according
to the information we have our naval
officers were deprived of the
opportunity to communicate and contact
their commanders the Kerch Strait is a
crucial but contested strip of water
Ukraine said it's boats were moving from
one major port Odessa to another
Mariupol and they reportedly gave the
Russian Navy advanced warning but a
Russian tanker was photographed blocking
the Straits parked under a recently
opened bridge that connects Crimea on
one side to the southern Russian
mainland on the other Russian fighter
jets were also scrambled to fly over the
area the Russian Federal Security
Service the FSB said that it has
irrefutable evidence that Kiev prepared
and orchestrated provocation in the
Black Sea these materials will soon be
made public it's Washington and NATO
both said that they were monitoring the
situation Kiev said it would seek
diplomatic and legal response and
involved the UN Security Council for now
tensions have subsided but it was a
violent incident between two enemies in
a volatile region and there will almost
certainly be fallout Alistair bundle Sky
News